la route a été longue pour pascal allard
et vientiane
mais ils sont maintenant parents deux
fois on n'a jamais pu en 2011 le couple
s'inscrit à la fois pour l'adoption
régulière et aussi comme famille
d'accueil pour adopter un enfant de
l'adpg et six bébés héloïse entrent dans
leur vie mais il leur faudra attendre
plus de deux ans avant de devenir
légalement ses parents quand on en a
marqué laden nous disait que d'entasser
dans une automobile
mais c'est vraiment pas toi qui conduis
une telle aubaine tu peux pas poteau qui
décide
l'autre demande d'adoption a mis huit
ans à se concrétiser
le petit raphaël leur a été confié
quelques heures après sa naissance des
chemins peuvent pas être un peu plus
compliqué mais tellement magnifique les
familles qui veulent adopter un enfant
au québec doivent se soumettre aux
règles et à la possibilité que les
parents biologiques se reprenne en main
et conservent leurs droits
c'est une charge émotionnelle terrible
convient un jeu de yoyo je dirai au
niveau émotionnel terrible en fout nous
fait on dit ça va marcher
le taux de réussite pour avoir un enfant
mal passé je vais 95 98 % de chance les
lobry effet les vincent savent qu'il
peut y avoir des écueils en 2009
un juge a retiré le garçon de 3 ans qui
vivait avec eux depuis 18 mois pour le
confier à son ombre le petit bonhomme de
la moitié de sa vie qu'elle va passer
avec nous et c'est comme on a peu tenu
compte de ça il faut être extrêmement
solide à tous les niveaux au niveau du
couple au niveau des ressources
matérielles émotionnel on se retrouve le
tout la troisième roue du carrosse on
est pris avec des contrastes intérêt
parce que l'on reçoit cet enfant alors
tout le monde s'entend pour dire qu'il
faut favoriser
attachement ça va créer de la stabilité
autour de 1200 enfants de la dpj de
montréal sont en famille d'accueil
mais 120 familles sont dans une
catégorie à part la banque mixte
puisqu'elle souhaite adopter l'enfant
qu'on leur a confiées
il s'occupe de l'enfant comme se paie le
leur mais en même temps ils ont par
exemple amener l'enfant à d'épisodes
supervise avec son parent ou ses parents
biologiques
ça leur fait venue des frustrations plus
des tensions dans leur poule
même s'ils savent que dans la majorité
des communes enfants l'eau sont adoptés
ils veulent évidemment pas tomber le
mans lille 3 4 % de gens qui viendraient
le retour au dollar un enfant du
document le rôle de la dpj et de veiller
au meilleur intérêt de l'enfant tout en
soutenant leurs parents biologiques les
attentes des familles adoptantes sont
énormes
face aux changements législatifs
annoncées par le gouvernement pour le
parent biologique comme plus de chance
de se reprendre puis vient un moment
donné mais c'est l'enfant qui en souffre
au bar web des enfants puis si tu peux
pas te reprendre un temps x je peux pas
t'en prendre est-ce qu'on favorise les
liens du sein où on favorise détachement
au niveau légal le statut jusqu où la
famille élargie peut aller pour
reprendre l'enfant cide à six mois on
voit que vraiment du côté de la maman
biologique et aucune chance ou si peu
alors oui on va aller avec vous vers la
majorité moi c'est ce que j'avais besoin
d'entendre
malgré tout ils ont plongé dans un
deuxième projet d'adoption concluant
celui là quelques mois plus tard la dpj
nous a proposé un nouveau projet et
on est tombé immédiatement amoureux de
ce petit garçon est
et on a embarqué c'est un boom c'est un
cadeau de cet enfant vraiment ce qui
n'empêche pas les lobry de penser à
celui qu'elle a perdu moi je suis resté
marqué c'était un deuil de nos enfants
c'est mon plus grand dilemme c'est de me
demander est-ce qu'il est heureux
aujourd'hui et chaque juif odienné
adopté à l'âge de 5 ans pascal allard
estime avoir été un enfant heureux à son
tour pascal deviendra un enfant désiré
chez lui contre j'avais été adoptée est
très jeune par des parents aimants
il se range du côté de ceux qui croient
que l'intérêt de l'enfant se mesure en
termes de stabilité d'attachement et pas
nécessairement avec sa famille
biologique
[Musique]